remember when we were told never to
reveal [ __ ] names online when we were
told that we should never post
information that could be used to
identify us and we're certainly not
encouraged to reveal contact details
thanks to giant companies wanting your
information for marketing and our love
of online social profiles that hole
privacy on the Internet plan went to
hell pretty quickly in fact I'd say a
lot of people seem to value having a
social profile over their privacy but
that's 2016 I guess and that's exactly
what Orwell banks on the
narrative-driven game from osmotics
Studios puts you into the shoes of Big
Brother you work as an investigator for
the government digging into the Facebook
sorry timeline pages of persons of
interest with the ultimate goal of
preventing terrorist attacks you know
when you're wondering what the deal is
with that cute tender girl so you dig
through our Instagram which takes you to
a tumbled page which takes you to our
twitter which has a link to our blog
yeah me neither anyway this is all a bit
like that you can link people together
find clues about organizations and
ringleaders uncover family info and
monitor evolving political stances until
you can form a concrete picture of who
might be responsible for the bad [ __ ]
going on the game highlights relevant
data chunks for you and all you need to
do is drag them into the system for the
government to act on that said not all
the info is relevant so you'll need to
discern what's useful what's misleading
and what you want the government to know
you'll need to weed out the red herrings
and choose the correct information to
relay from contradictory statements and
evidence forming a profile of
individuals based only on their digital
presence is surprisingly enjoyable and
frighteningly accurate when you think
about how much of yourself you put
online correlating ex bandmember
listings alongside information found on
family webpages might suggest
relationships that have since
deteriorated while reading comments on
timeline post gives you an idea of how
political stances and social
revolutionary involvement has changed
for each person of interest over time
the only annoying thing that I ran into
is that the game was broken up into
chapters and as a result it only wants
you to investigate certain people at
certain
times so while someone appeared
extremely suspicious to me in the first
chapter I was unable to abandon my data
mining of someone I thought to be
innocent - Percy what I thought was a
more viable lead this kind of interface
driven investigation game relies on you
lagging behind the game to be really
effective the game absolutely has to
know more than you at all times much
like her story always did it becomes
problematic when you begin to engage
with the story but the mechanics hold
you back from what feels like a natural
progression of your investigation but
all well still touches on interesting
elements like the expense of the
Internet our social spaces surveillance
States and the age of information it
lets you hack phone and text
conversations or read newspaper articles
explore webpages and following new leads
Orwell's next chapter arrives on the
27th of October and despite my issues
with the game I am seriously counting
down the days until I can jump back in
Orwell's first chapter is available now
on Steam as a free demo I'm hoping the
rift between my character essentially me
and government I work for becomes larger
I hope that I'm asked to make choices on
what information to dispense based on my
own sense of morality not just what will
help the investigation
and I look forward to seeing if the game
can broaden the complexities its
narrative and my role in uncovering the
truth there are five chapters in total
which it's your out weekly from now
until November 17 so if you want to play
your part and flex your cyber stalking
skills Orwell may well be worth your
time